mainstream entertainment awards often
overlook
horror but american horror story is so
well made that emmy voters bestow it
with accolades year after year
but what exactly goes into making the
creepy
award-winning anthology series we shine
a light on the untold truth of american
horror story
in addition to legendary oscar winners
like jessica lang and kathy bates
american horror story has made stars of
up-and-comers like emma roberts and evan
peters and proved to the world long
before a star is born that lady gaga
could act
it's hard to believe that some
performers couldn't or didn't want to be
involved with the top-rated show
chris zilka booked a two-episode stint
on asylum as a deaf man but a few months
later he exited because he didn't want
to shave his head
a requirement of the role ryan murphy
has also dutifully pursued a few dream
cast members albeit
unsuccessfully among the targets he has
revealed
michelle pfeiffer michael chiklis and
rhys witherspoon
talking about the latter to
entertainment weekly murphy said i
wanted her to play something really
twisted
and effed up but she's always booked
neil patrick harris and his husband
david burka appeared in freak show
although murphy earlier pursued the
couple for murder house he wanted them
to portray the bickering pair ultimately
played by zachary quinto and teddy sears
harris explained to rolling stone why
they skipped out on the park referring
to the couple's roles in
a very harold and kumar 3d christmas we
had just played ourselves as a couple
not
getting along i thought it just seems
weird to do that twice
as individual actors to play a couple
that hate each other twice so
i said no that we shouldn't do it the
eighth season of american horror story
dubbed apocalypse
tied together characters from multiple
seasons in the ultimate crossover event
to face the ultimate evil michael
langdon the offspring of satan
the antichrist in the sixth episode of
the story
return to murder house viewers learn
that michael realizes his evil abilities
in full after a visit from anton levay
and his top lieutenants who ritually and
brutally sacrifice a woman
remove her beating heart and give it
over to the young embodiment of true
evil to feast upon
it was a deeply upsetting scene for many
viewers but in a different way for the
real-life
church of satan anton levay was a real
person who really did found the church
of satan
and wrote several books espousing the
beliefs of the 10 000 strong
organization
present day church of satan leaders
objected to the portrayal of the church
on american horror story
tweeting about their disapproval in
october 2018 and
pointing out the inaccuracies in the
adaptation
when ryan murphy talked to the hollywood
reporter regarding sarah paulson's
portrayal of bett and doc tatler during
the fourth season of american horror
story he couldn't hold back his
overwhelming praise
saying it's absolutely the most
challenging thing
i've ever seen any actor do ever
it was really terrifying as you might
imagine i didn't know how in the world
we were going to do it
and it's a really scary thing to to act
by yourself
the dual role found paulson playing
conjoined twins with two heads and one
body
living in a traveling sideshow on
american horror story freak show it was
also
one of the most challenging things the
show's special effects artists
ever had to attempt it required a lot of
old-fashioned trickery
labor and digital manipulation for
paulson to convincingly play
both characters first the effects team
took a mold of paulson's own head and
used it to build two sophisticated
prosthetic heads
as murphy explained so when sarah is
doing her coverage where she's dot
she has on a fake head to her left which
is bet and it moves
she literally has to do scenes with
herself
those scenes took as long as 15 hours to
shoot
because everything with the tattlers had
to be filmed for close-up
in medium shots for effects and from
various angles
twice scream queens began life as an
idea for a standalone
ahs spin-off season featuring characters
from the coven season of american horror
story
however the show with the same creator
and many of the same cast members went
the other way
and inspired a season of american horror
story
scream queens like american horror story
was an anthology
telling a different story each season
albeit featuring the same characters
in its first iteration in 2015 a killer
ran wild on a college campus
while the first season of scream queens
was running on fox
co-star oliver hudson said on braavos
watch what happens live
that creator ryan murphy had told him
that the show in the event that it was
renewed for a second season would shift
its setting from a university to a
summer camp
that of course didn't happen fox renewed
scream queens and the second season took
place in a hospital
however four years later the eighth
season of american horror story debuted
on fx
a lengthy homage to 1980s slasher movies
the season subtitled
1984 took place primarily at camp
redwood a summer camp
it also starred billy lourd a holdover
from the scream queens cast
american horror story freak show takes
place in florida among the denizens of
one of the few remaining
cabinet of curiosities shows in 1952.
a highlight of the season is the
recurring motif of anachronistic music
from musicians like nirvana and david
bowie
meaning characters said in the show's
world of the early 50s sing
very famous songs recorded decades later
ryan murphy explained that the songs
were carefully selected for freak show
and for good reason as he explained we
decided we only were going to highlight
musical artists who at some point in
their career had identified themselves
as feeling like
freaks or misfits or outcasts which our
people
are going through in american horror
story hotel
evan peters portrayed mr march who
turned out to be arguably
the most purely evil character in the
show's long list of
purely evil characters trapping
torturing and
murdering people in the hotel cortez
there are places in my murder palace
that have sat in cold neglect for far
too long
you could put them to good use oh boy
it's quite upsetting that according to
ryan murphy in entertainment weekly
mr march is based on a real horrific
person
that individual is h.h holmes who during
the chicago world's fair in 1893
opened and utilized a quote hotel of
horrors
world's fair visitors who tragically
chose to board at holmes's hotel would
find their rooms
soundproof and windowless all the better
for homes to murder them via gassing or
other means secret passageways allowed
him to remove bodies without detection
to the basement
where he'd destroy the evidence in a
furnace he was caught in 1894 and
executed two years later american horror
story hotel
took inspiration in part from the
ghastly horrors committed by hh homes
and seemingly from something more modern
and ambiguous as well
the hotel cortez is loosely based on the
cecil hotel a structure in the skid row
area of downtown los angeles
that's hosted countless tourists and
transients
as well as murderers and mysteries
austrian serial killer jack untewager
resided at the hotel for a while as did
richard ramirez
the murderer known as the night stalker
he's even a character in american horror
story hotel
the one incident that really moved the
needle for american horror story creator
ryan murphy was the story of elisa lynn
as explored in the 2021 netflix
documentary crime scene the vanishing at
the cecil hotel
canadian student lem stayed at the cecil
during a trip to los
angeles in 2013 only to disappear an
internet driven manhunt ensued
especially after the release of a
bizarre surveillance video of lam
acting erratically in a cecil hotel
elevator a few days later
lamb's body was discovered in a rooftop
water tank murphy summed up the puzzling
circumstances
at a television critics association
event in august 2015.
a girl got in an elevator in a downtown
hotel
she was never seen again the sinister
sounding postmodern opening sequence for
american horror story seems tailor-made
for the show
a combination of spooky forbidding and
hypnotic musical themes
punctuated by jarring jump-scare sounds
surprisingly
the bulk of it comes from a 20-year-old
class project
back in 1998 cesar davila isari was a
sophomore at the university of puerto
rico
for a music history class he created a
primitive digital audio track using cool
edit 96
on his windows 98 computer stretching
mixing and
combining various sounds with white
noise for example the song's first
dissonant moment comes from a clip of
davila azari dropping wire hangers on a
tile floor
when he was done davila azari gave it to
his friend gabrielle diaz who went on to
work as a video editor on the first
season of american horror story
he used avila azari's track as a
placeholder but producers liked it so
much
they decided to keep it for technical
and legal reasons
show composer charlie klauser of nine
inch nails recreated and spruced it up
with davila azari's blessing
apart from a couple of appearances as
church of satan cardinal samantha crowe
in the apocalypse season actor naomi
grossman left her mark on the american
horror story franchise in the second
season
asylum story she portrayed pepper a
woman who suffers from microcephaly
which means
someone having a smaller than normal
head she also possesses many other
notable physical traits such as large
ears jutting teeth
a mostly shaved paint and a top knot
grossman is
almost unrecognizable as pepper and her
physical transformation into the
character for each episode of asylum
was a long and involved process with
grossman telling entertainment weekly
the entire process takes about two and a
half to three hours and that's with two
men working the entire time freckles and
veins were drawn on grossman's skin and
then came
extensive prosthetics which included a
forehead
complete with punched in eyebrows a nose
ears
and even a bumpy little spine piece for
my back
grossman was also outfitted for a set of
false teeth which altered the shape of
her mouth and face
grossman additionally revealed that she
couldn't even use one of her eyes thanks
to a lens she had to wear
songs recorded by fleetwood mac as well
as that band's
stevie nicks permeate the soundtracks of
multiple american horror story seasons
that's logical as nyx has long been
associated with witches dark spirits and
other
spooky stuff that's abundant in the ryan
murphy horror anthology
nyx's bewitching presence is felt most
strongly in the third american horror
story subtitled coven where lily rabe
plays a witch who deeply loves nyx's
music even before she finds out the
singer is an actual
practicing witch too nix makes a cameo
late in the season
and it was tough for american horror
story producers to make it happen
nyx was friendly with ahs creators ryan
murphy and brad falchuk having lent a
hand on a fleetwood mac
tribute episode of their series glee for
american horror story nyx told the los
angeles times that the creators asked if
they could use her music again
and when they explained that her songs
were an integral aspect of the lonely
character misty day
nyx acquiesced when murphy asked her to
appear
she was terrified at first she had a
terrible time acting in a fourth grade
play
and had quote vowed to stay away
from acting forever this shaw
has danced across the stages of the
world
and now it's yours and good luck
with the seven wonders each year the
story setting and characters are
different
but the actors remain the same from the
beginning of the american horror story
anthology concept creator ryan murphy
has utilized a collective of performers
with many of them dutifully returning
for each successive season
however when it came time to shoot
season 9 1984
murphy had to make due without the use
of some of his most venerable actors
for example evan peters starred in eight
seasons then left the show citing
burnout and
an aversion to getting typecast in
horror rules sarah paulson also appeared
in each of the first eight tales
and jessica lang bowed out after four
seasons then had a small role reprising
cameo in the eighth season which tied
together several
different disparate american horror
stories together it also involved a
large
number of actors which stretched fx's
budget with fx ceo john
landgraf telling the rap it was a
monster in terms of the size of the cast
cost of that cast according to landgraf
murphy had to quote
clean the slate start over when american
horror story 1984 debuted it boasted a
cast composed mostly of new
and latter day rivals to the franchise
after the soft reboot of american horror
story was announced in the form of an
80s horror movie influenced season
called 1984
a series fan and video editor named cory
vega made a pre-emptive cut of what he
thought the upcoming episode's opening
credit sequence ought to look like
in short vega thought it should look
extremely 80s he put together a rapid
fire clip montage that included shots of
aerobics
instructors neon colored cars
moonwalking and neon graphics
and because it's supposed to be an
american horror story clip
lots of blood and gore permeated it all
the video spread around the internet
until it reached a very influential
figure
co-creator and producer ryan murphy
murphy wrote on instagram that he was
such a fan of the edit that he hired
vega to recreate his video with
ahs titles designer kyle cooper to use
in 1984.
from 2011 to 2019 a new edition of
american horror story
aired every fall on fx the network
ordered a 10th season in the summer of
2018
before season 8 had aired and before 9
had entered production
but then 2020 came and went without a
new horror
pushed back by fx due to coronavirus
production delays
creator ryan murphy already had a lot on
his plate as fx also ordered a spin-off
called american horror stories
in which each episode would tell a
single story and in 2019 he signed a 300
million
deal to move his productions to netflix
filming being delayed by many months
even threatened to change the nature of
the series as murphy told
the rap a lot of what i was going to
shoot was dependent on a very specific
moment
it was a weather dependent show i don't
know what i'm going to do next with that
show i don't know if i'll accelerate
another season
or wait till next year to shoot this one
while reports suggested filming would
begin in december 2020
filming permits were filed for a
february 2021 shoot in provincetown
massachusetts under the name
pilgrim before american horror story
debuted in 2011 co-creator ryan murphy
was best known as one of the minds
behind glee
a show so happy and positive that it was
literally about a bunch of high school
kids
gaining self-esteem by singing and
dancing to familiar pop songs
murphy then went directly from his high
school musical to a house full of murder
ghosts suicide and a rubber man what
happened to murphy that he could make
such a switch
he later revealed in an interview with
elle saying i was like
i can't write any more nice speeches for
these glee kids about love and tolerance
and togetherness
to that end he wrote a show about sex
murder and depravity instead
as for a more direct trajectory of what
inspired ryan murphy
best known for teen fare to construct an
interconnected universe of horrors both
supernatural and psychological
he looked to two old favorites from the
1970s as murphy told
interview like all my tv shows it's
rooted in a childhood obsession
two actually dark shadows and a movie
called don't look now
he was referring to a gothic tv daytime
serial about
a vampire named barnabas collins and a
donald sutherland movie about parents in
the throes of grief after the death of a
child
he went on to say what i really wanted
to do was my version of dark shadows
where there are creatures and a soap
opera and sex because
my grandmother used to make me watch
dark shadows as punishment
american horror story also allowed ryan
murphy to write a wrong from his days on
glee
he'd wanted sarah paulson to play emma
pillsbury the ocd afflicted high school
guidance counselor eventually portrayed
by jaime mays but paulson was unable
because she was starring in a broadway
play at the time
murphy finally found a place for paulson
as medium billie dean howard the first
of many memorable ahs
rules she would step into a close
creative ally to murphy
paulson came into the writer director's
inner circle at the suggestion of
american horror story mainstage escalane
lang and paulson had acted together in a
2005 broadway revival of the tennessee
williams classic the glass menagerie
in 2011 when development for the first
season of american horror story was
underway
and jessica lange had been cast in the
lead role of constance langdon
she approached murphy with the request
to quote
find something for paulson lots of
people have a fear of clowns known as
coulrophobia
it must be something about their frozen
exaggerated and
untrustworthy grins or how their
identity is concealed under white face
paint
american horror story aptly exploited
those fears in its freak show season
featuring john carroll lynch as the
monstrous twisty the clown
who isn't so much a children's party
entertainer as the guy who kills people
with scissors and
locks kids in an old school bus perhaps
unsurprisingly this subplot upsets some
real life clowns as clowns of america
president glenn kohlberger
said in a response to freak show in 2014
hollywood makes money sensationalizing
the norm
they can take any situation no matter
how good or pure and turn it into a
nightmare
we do not support in any way shape or
form
any medium that sensationalizes or adds
to coulrophobia
the protests flared up again in 2017
when american horror story cult
once again featured evil clowns world
clown association president pam moody
told the detroit free press
the role of a clown persona regardless
of their style of clowning
is meant to bring joy and laughter to
bring humor to a hurting world
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one